BUT FIRST, WHEN BIRTHRIGHT GOES
WRONG.
THAT'S THE FOCUS OF TONIGHT'S
ANGLE.
FROM THE SECOND PRESIDENT TRUMP
ANNOUNCES PLANS TO ADDRESS
BIRTHRIGHT CITIZENSHIP EARLIER
TODAY, THE LEFT FREAK OUT.
HERE'S WHAT THE PRESIDENT TOLD
AXIOS.
>> President Trump: WE ARE THE
ONLY COUNTRY IN THE WORLD WHERE
A PERSON COMES IN AND HAS A BABY
AND THAT BABY IS ESSENTIALLY A
CITIZEN OF THE UNITED STATES FOR
85 YEARS WITH ALL THOSE
BENEFITS.
IT'S RIDICULOUS AND IT HAS TO
END.
>> HAVE YOU TALKED ABOUT THAT
WITH COUNCIL?
>> SO WE ARE PROTEST.
PROCESS?
>> Laura: THEY WERE QUICK TO
ANNOUNCE THE PRESIDENT AND
CONDEMN EVEN RAISING THE IDEA OF
ENDING BIRTHRIGHT CITIZENSHIP.
>> IS IF WE NEEDED IT, THERE'S
MORE EVIDENCE THAT IMMIGRATION
REMAINS THE PRESIDENT'S
ANIMATING ISSUE.
THIS NEW PROPOSAL TO END
BIRTHRIGHT CITIZENSHIP.
>> IS TALKING ABOUT BIRTHRIGHT
CITIZENSHIP AND I THINK HE'S
DONE NOT JUST SIMPLY TO INFLAME
THE ISSUE.
>> I MEAN, THIS IS THE HARD-LINE
IMMIGRATION MESSAGE, THE FEAR OF
IMMIGRANTS CHANGING THE WAY OF
LIFE OF AMERICANS.
>> IT HEARKENS BACK TO SOME OF
THE DARKEST CHAPTERS OF
AMERICAN'S HISTORY WHERE IN
1857, THE SCOTT DECISION.
>> Laura: MOVE OVER
ENCYCLOPEDIA BRITANNICA.
THIS IS DEFAULT BEHAVIOR OF ALL
THOSE DEFLECTED WITH TRUMP
DERANGEMENT SYNDROME.
WHEN FACED WITH AN INCONVENIENT
TROOP.
THEY DEMONIZE THE PRESIDENT, AND
DISMISSED OUT OF HAND OF THE
ISSUE.
HEAVEN FORBID WE ACTUALLY
PRESENT THE AMERICAN PEOPLE WITH
A FACTUAL UNBIASED PRESENTATION
OF THE ISSUE.
FIRST OF ALL, PRESIDENT TRUMP
HAD ALREADY COMMITTED TO ENDING
BIRTHRIGHT CITIZENSHIP DURING
THE CAMPAIGN, SO ASIDE FROM HIS
MENTIONING THE DRAFTING OF
EXECUTIVE ORDER IN THE PATHWAY
TO FULFILLING HIS PROMISE, IT'S
HARDLY A NEWS FLASH.
AND WHY IS THIS AN IMPORTANT
ISSUE IN THE FIRST PLACE WITH
THE PRESIDENT?
A LOT OF IT GOES FOR THE MONEY.
CONSIDER THE NUMBER OF CHILDREN
BORN TO ILLEGALS EACH YEAR.
BACK IN 2010, THE CENTER FOR
IMMIGRATION STUDIES ESTIMATED
THAT BETWEEN 300,400,000 ARE
BORN TO ILLEGAL ALIENS IN THE
UNITED STATES ANNUALLY.
NOW THAT FIGURE IS FOUND TO BE A
LOT HIGHER TODAY GIVEN THE NEW
RESEARCH THAT THE NUMBER OF
ILLEGALS IN THE U.S. IS AT LEAST
DOUBLE WHAT WAS ORIGINALLY
THOUGHT.
OR, ABOUT 22 MILLION.
LET'S CONSERVATIVELY SAY THAT
400,000 CHILDREN ARE BORN EVERY
YEAR IN THE UNITED STATES TO
ILLEGAL IMMIGRANTS.
WHILE THOSE ARE PEOPLE THAT
HARDWORKING U.S. TAXPAYERS HAVE
TO EDUCATE, AND FOR WHOM THEY
PROVIDE HEALTH CARE, AND IN MANY
CASES FOOD STAMPS.
OBVIOUSLY INFRASTRUCTURE,
ET CETERA, ET CETERA.
CIS ESTIMATES THAT THE ANNUAL
COST TO THE U.S. TAXPAYERS OF
CHILDREN BORN TO ILLEGAL ALIENS
IS A STAGGERING $2.4 BILLION.
YOU THINK OUR VETS AND OUR
HOMELESS AND OUR INNER CITY
SCHOOLS COULD USE THAT MONEY?
MAYBE WE COULD EVEN PAY DOWN
SOME OF THE DEBT.
TO BORROW DOWN A LITTLE FURTHER,
A 2015 CIS REPORT FOUND 51% OF
IMMIGRANT HEADED HOUSEHOLDS USED
AT LEAST ONE FEDERAL PROGRAM.
CASH, FOOD, HOUSING OR MEDICAL
CARE COMPARED TO ONLY 30% OF
NATIVE HOUSEHOLDS.
AND WE AREN'T JUST TALKING BY
THE WAY ABOUT FOLKS ON THESE
OVER STAYS OR WHO CROSS THE
BORDER ILLEGALLY.
MANY OF YOU WOULD BE STUNNED IT
TO KNOW THAT THERE ARE ENTIRE
INDUSTRIES BOTH HERE AND ABROAD
THAT ARE NOW DEVOTED TO GAINING
THE BIRTHRIGHT CITIZENSHIP
SYSTEM.
IT'S CALLED BIRTH TOURISM AND
ITS BECOME BIG BUSINESS IN THE
UNITED STATES, ATTRACTING
IMMIGRANTS FROM CHINA, TAIWAN,
MEXICO, RUSSIA, AND TURKEY.
WHAT THEY DO IS THEY PURCHASE
PACKAGE DEALS, WHERE THEY COME
TO THE U.S. FOR A MONTH OR
SEVERAL MONTHS AND HAVE THEIR
BABY ON AMERICAN SOIL.
FOR UPWARDS OF $50,000 TO THOSE
FOREIGNERS GUARANTEED U.S.
CITIZENSHIP FOR THEIR CHILDREN.
IT'S WILD.
AND THEY ALSO CAN SPONSOR THE
PARENTS FOR GREEN CARDS.
THAT'S PRETTY NIFTY.
SO I'M SURE THIS IS WHAT OUR
FOUNDERS INTENDED WHEN THEY WERE
DRAFTING THE 14TH AMENDMENT.
CONTRARY TO WHAT OBAMA THE
MANTRA IS PROVOKING A
CONVERSATION THAT I THINK IS
SORELY NEEDED IN THE COUNTRY.
RATHER THAN JUST CASTIGATING THE
PRESIDENT OR CARICATURING HIS
POSITION.
WHY NOT HAVE A SUBSTANTIVE
DEBATE ON IT.